well I have a story out of the UK  Britain's Princess Charlotte started her  first day of school today and she  arrived with her family look at her  right there with her brother for the  head teacher said in a statement  released back in May we are delighted  that the Duke and Duchess of Cambridge  have decided that Princess Charlotte  will join her brother Prince George yes  I have to admit I'm a little you know I  have a certain affinity for this story  because my daughter went back to school  today little journey there she is yeah I  saw that  also in this story that Kate Middleton  wasn't able to make George's first day  because she was going through morning  sickness so of course you know heart  goes out to the little kids when they  can't be there but I will be picking her  up from school so she's excited about  that